-Our next guest is
an award-winning journalist
and correspondent you know best
from his long-running work
on "Dateline." The 30th season
premieres this Friday,
September 24th,
right here on NBC.
Please welcome to the show
and the studio Keith Morrison.
[ Applause ]
-Wow.
[ Laughs ]
-Welcome back. Thank you
so much for being here.
Really appreciate it.
Come on up.
-Thank you.
Well, well, well.
This is where you live, huh?
-This is where I live.
It's not too bad, right?
-I thought you were
at that Italian restaurant
most of the time.
-No, that's not me.
You're thinking of someone else.
30 seasons!
-I know.
I know.
-Can you believe it?
-Believe what?
-That it's 30 seasons?
-Oh, that. Oh, that. Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
No, I can't,
as a matter of fact.
You know, it goes by
about in a week and a half.
-Yeah.
-When you started --
-Didn't I see you about
a week and a half ago?
-It felt like a week --
You were actually --
The first time you were here,
you were in our studio,
was the first season
of our show.
We did a sketch together
where --
-Which was last week.
-It felt like last week.
-Huh.
-But it was --
But would you believe
it was almost seven years ago
that you were here?
Isn't that crazy?
-Amazing. Yeah.
-When did you know
"Dateline" was working?
-You know, it -- it actually
worked from the very beginning.
It worked so well
from the very beginning
that they wanted the show on
five nights a week.
-Yeah.
-Even when we didn't do crime,
it worked quite well.
And there were a lot of stories
I loved doing.
Stories about a whale
or a wolf or...
-Yeah.
-You know?
-Do you -- Do they
let you do many whale
or wolf stories these days?
-No whale and
wolf stories anymore, no.
-No. That's too bad.
'Cause, I mean,
I feel like you were at the --
at the forefront
of this true crime --
-Of the whale -- Oh, no.
Of the true crime.
-No, no. The whale.
You guys were way at the end
of the whale --
the whale moment.
-Sure.
-But you guys were true crime.
-Yeah, it's true.
It's true.
And we discovered it
kind of by accident,
I guess you could say.
But there were -- there were
good stories out there,
which were crime stories.
We did a couple of them.
They did extraordinarily well,
compared to the rest
of the programs,
so we did more of them.
-Yeah.
-And then we just made them
longer and longer and longer.
-And the world
has done a nice job
by continuing
to provide you crimes.
-They do that.
-Yeah.
-Yeah. Uh-huh. Yeah.
-And -- [ Chuckles ]
When you -- When you --
When they bring them to you,
when they say, "Hey, Keith,
here's a new story.
Here's a woman."
It does seem like a lot of wives
want to get rid
of their husbands.
Is that -- Would you say
thematically that has --
-You know, I think that's --
I think that's a fantasy
by some people.
-Yeah. I think you may -- Maybe
they don't want to act on it,
but they don't mind watching
a "Dateline" or two about it.
-The sad truth, it's usually
the other way around.
So it makes a better story,
you know?
-Right. That's true.
-It's the dog-bites-man story.
-Yeah, exactly.
Everybody's like, "Finally --
Finally they're getting theirs."
-Yeah.
-Did you know that your voice
would be a perfect fit
for these kinds of stories?
-It is? No. No.
-You didn't know?
-Well, who -- Come on, now.
What are we doing here, anyway?
No, I didn't actually.
I had no idea.
-Yeah, but that seems to be one
of the nice surprises about it.
-But it's -- it's odd. Yeah.
You know,
people do imitations of it.
-Bill Hader did a famous
imitation of you on "SNL."
When we were together
the first time,
I texted him and said,
"I hope you're jealous,
'cause I'm with the real --
the real Keith Morrison."
-Yeah. Uh-huh. Yeah.
-Did you enjoy
his impression of you?
-It was -- Yes.
-Okay.
-I did, and I didn't.
Have you ever --
Have you had some --
somebody do
an impression of you?
-Yeah.
-In kind of a parody like that?
-Yeah, but not quite like that.
-Yeah.
-
I mean, I feel like he really...
-So, if the first time
you ever saw it,
you were unprepared for it
and it was
on national television...
-Right.
-On "Saturday Night Live."
And you turn on the TV,
and somebody's doing that.
-Is that how --
Did you see it first
or did you get a bunch
of texts from people?
-No. Well, I got --
My daughter texted me.
-Yeah. Was she happy?
Did your daughter like it?
-She was laughing her head off.
-Okay, well, that's good.
-So --
-I think that's a good sign,
if your daughter
laughs her head off.
-Yeah, well -- But it does
a wonderful thing, actually,
for a person's sense
of him or herself.
-I think so, too.
-It's a -- It's a --
You know, it's an amazing thing.
It feels -- makes you feel good,
but at the same time, you
realize even when you feel good,
even when you feel noticed and
appreciated, you're an idiot.
You always were an idiot.
-I don't think that's --
I don't think
that's the takeaway.
One thing that I feel like
proves you're not an idiot
is you --
There's an Instagram account
which is all photos of you
leaning against things.
-I never lean.
-This is something that you --
-That's fake photography.
-Will you explain why you have
decided to lean against things?
-I didn't decide.
It was just -- You know --
-Here. Here's another example.
-Look. You know what happened?
When people talk --
Have you watched the news?
-I've watched the news
once or twice.
-Once or twice, yeah.
So, they don't do it
quite so much anymore.
But it used to be
that you'd see some person
walking along the street,
gesticulating
with his or her hands
and walking toward a camera
or walking somewhere
and kind of telling you what --
And I always thought
that looked ridiculous.
I liked the people involved,
but why are they doing that?
And so --
-So do you mean, like,
a news story starts
and someone's walking towards
camera, like,
telling you what happened.
-Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
-And you didn't like it?
-I didn't like it. No.
-So you came up with the lean?
-[ Scoffs ]
What do you mean "came up with"?
I was leaning to begin with.
-You were leaning
to begin with,
but I feel like --
-I'm leaning right now.
-But, look --
I -- I mean, look, at this.
This --
I mean, it's such a pro move.
Like, this guy -- I want to hear
what this guy has to say.
-Yeah.
He's leaning on a fence.
-The guy's leaning
on the fence.
He's not in a rush.
He wants to tell you a story.
-Barbed wire fence.
-Yeah, that part was weird
to me, that you would choose
to not lean against the post.
-You have no idea
how painful that was.
-Yeah. And then --
I remember that episode,
a solitary tear
rolled down your face.
-That's right.
-As the -- As the barb
cut through your sweater.
-Uh-huh. Yeah.
-This one somebody mocked up.
I like that a good deal.
-No, that's real.
-That's real? That's him?
-That's the only real one.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey. Will you --
-Makes sense, don't you think?
-You have -- I feel like
when I do a tease for our
upcoming guests, they're good.
You know, I think people
are excited to see them.
But I feel like I don't add
the sort of drama...
-Ah.
-...that you could.
Do you mind -- Do you mind
teasing our guests
for tomorrow night?
It's John Kerry
and Jim Gaffigan.
-You have John Kerry on
tomorrow night?
-That's pretty good, right?
-That is pretty good.
-So, uh, do you mind?
-I don't mind at all.
Join us tomorrow, when former
Secretary of State John Kerry
shares a secret
that changes everything.
And when funny man
Jim Gaffigan swings by,
the laughter stops...
and the screaming begins.
Tomorrow on
"Late Night with Seth Meyers."
-See, I think that's
gonna be big for us.
I think that's gonna be
really big for us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're also -- You're also doing
a lot of podcasting now,
which seems like a perfect fit.
-We are doing podcasts.
Which is -- Yeah,
they don't have to look
at my face that way.
You can just talk to them.
-Do people ever recognize you
from your voice first
on the street?
-All the time, yeah.
-Yeah.
And what do they say to you?
-"Why do you talk
that funny way?"
-Well, that seems like
a very fair question.
30 seasons. Congratulations.
-Thank you very much.
-It's really an accomplishment.
And we really appreciate
you being with us.
30th season of "Dateline"
premieres this Friday
at 9:00 p.m. here on NBC.